this gives the police a temptation when
you give them the power so forfeiture
they got to choose between themselves or
the public why do we want to put them in
that position hi I'm Zach why smaller
for reason TV we're here with Bart
Wilson the Donald p Kennedy endowed
chair of economics and law at Chapman
University where he specializes in the
field of experimental economics which
seeks to test economic theory in the
laboratory the topic of your latest
study was civil asset forfeiture a topic
that people at the Institute for justice
which provided a grant for this study of
been talking about for a long time
libertarians have been talking about it
for a long time and it was written up in
the Washington Post they're doing a
three-part series on it right now which
cites your study The New Yorker did a
big story on it it's seeping into the
public consciousness but for the people
who might not know what it is yet let's
start with the basics what exactly is
civil asset forfeiture which states that
allow civil forfeiture the law
enforcement are allowed to seize
property that they suspect being part of
a crime even though the owners of the
property may not be arrested for a crime
and in most cases they can keep all or
some of those proceeds so this can be
the cash from a drug deal or it can be
actually seizing cars or homes and then
reselling it the controversy comes in
because some people say that creates an
incentive to seize more and more
properties so-called policing for profit
other people say that it's a good thing
because then the police departments
raise revenue on their own and then they
can use those resources to fight more
crimes essentially attacks on criminals
this is the controversy that you were
trying to get at in the questions you
were trying to answer how did you go
about doing that in a study I'm an
experimental economists so I build
models of a simplified world and then
take it to the laboratory and see what
undergraduates do with it and so we
wanted to look at these trade-offs in
terms of will will the law enforcement
subjects go after the drugs or will they
wait and try to get the cash in order to
fight more crime or will they just take
the cash and that's it in bart Wilson's
world for undergraduate students move
avatars around a 2d game board the red
avatar represents law enforcement the
sharing the three blue avatars represent
the public and they mostly scoot around
picking up tokens were three cents each
that is they accumulate wealth the
sheriff gets paid for collecting tokens
and for knocking down walls with hammers
that knocking down walls is like
fighting crime inside the walls are more
tokens some are red tokens that only the
sheriff can pick up these are assets
like drug money off limits to the
general public pastel tokens represent
the public benefits of a safer crime
free neighborhood only blue avatars can
acquire those the brightly colored
tokens represent another kind of
property the cops concedes like the
house of a woman whose son sells drugs
on the porch without her knowledge or
the cash seized during a routine highway
stop property that the police could
relinquish to the public or keep for
themselves as soon as you give them
civil forfeiture they are collecting 95
to ninety seven percent of all those
tokens they barely have any there for
the public maybe it seems obvious that
most people will keep the money rather
than handing it over to others but
police department's argue just the
opposite when they say that civil
forfeiture is still a win-win because
police use the seized property to invest
in more crime fight so this version of
the game tests those incentives the
sheriff can use the money earned from
solving a crime and seizing illegal
assets to buy another hammer break
another wall and give the public access
to their tokens but doing that would eat
into his profits by as much as six cents
how many tokens he leaves on the board
in order to make the real better off law
enforcement has to leave that there for
them to be better off because if they
collect them all then public is even
better off so we're the sheriff's nice
to their fellow players or did they
squeeze out as much money as possible in
general at best they're not worse off
sometimes they're worse off and
sometimes there but the same but never
are they better off than when they have
no civil forfeiture which means they're
not investing enough in the fighting
additional crimes and allowing the
public to consume those extras those
extra tokens one of the more amusing and
lightening parts was actually looking at
the comments that the players were
making some of the comments you found
included OMG he's stealing them all he
has too much power red has no incentive
to help us I feel so powerless some Reds
just want to see the world burn what
kind of insights of these comments give
us they took it very seriously and they
were very upset the same way people feel
when it happens in the naturally
occurring world we know you get stopped
by the police they take the cash in your
car you feel powerless and it's exactly
what the blue avatars felt the title of
the study is bad laws bad apples what
does this study say about that question
that we started with our bad rules to
blame or are there just a few bad actors
that are ruining things it's not a few
people just abusing it if the net that
this is the modal tendency to abuse but
you take that power away those same
people then in our design help the
public even when they don't have a
financial incentive to do so they could
choose just to make maximize earnings
and not help the people up but they then
do so so for me that's pretty strong
evidence that it's the rules that are
creating the incentives for them to to a
police for profit how do you extrapolate
what happens in a simulation of
undergraduates playing a computer game
to what police officers are doing in the
real world these results are not kind of
you know 6535 you know 7030 these are 95
5 kind of behaviors that we see
accumulated over course of an hour
pyramid and its robust from group after
group after group and so undergraduates
or humans to and and this seems to be a
robust finding that we're seeing in our
sample this gives the police a
temptation when faced with a zero-sum
world when you give them the power civil
forfeiture they got to choose between
themselves or the public why do we want
to put them in that position we don't do
it with double jeopardy we don't do with
innocent until proven guilty for we
could say oh they're just a few bad
prosecutors out there who keep punishing
try to go after the same people no we
just say we're not going to allow them
that possibility there's a temptation a
human temptation to put yourself before
others when it's just you or me Bart
Wilson thank you very much for talking
to us glad to thank you for reason TV
I'm Zack why smaller for further
discussion of experimental economics as
a field of study check out our previous
interview with Wilson by clicking on the
displayed video now